can you make some noise are you ready
yeah I like that but let me show you how
we used to do get involved good if I was
going when I was growing up in the 90s
okay he shot a bad on me like hold on I
right now hold on do you remember where
you used to beatbox me to sleep yeah
yeah I remember I remember them day and
she was a little baby we would do
something like this
Horta harder harder harder harder yeah I
remember the video this is like a little
calling me to loser oh shut up but a lot
of people out there don't really know
what beatboxing means they don't know
where it started from right right where
it came from
right so much you give them a little
history just a tickle give it a history
don't worry comes from beatbox started
here in New York you would have that's
right that's right
New York everybody like yeah well we
from st. Louis
we don't know put your hands down
but beatbox started here in New York
what you would have is then when we
would go to parties you would have the
deejay and you have the rapper but
because I don't have electricity coming
out I mean we have to emulate what the
beats was doing so when when you will
see the beatboxing you will see us over
to the side then you will see a rapper
and when a rapper began to write will do
a simple beat because back then the
beats was simple those were simple beats
but now you got folks that want to do
all type of stuff with a beats now and
they want to humiliate their father
which is not right when you want to
humiliate the person that take care of
you pay all your tuition
especially when you have 50 million
people that just go around and call you
the loser well I'm taking at the heart
but now we do something different than
our house so we have these jam sessions
and our jam sessions consist of us
jamming in church yeah why Church go and
look at each other that and we'll text
the feet
each other all will be in the kitchen
cooking road trips boiler standing right
there in the corner are you listening
I'm kidding but you know what we're
talking all about this jam session
everything yeah
Oh
oh yes big cats football cats skip skip
thank you